cela fait deux mois que david n'a pas
revu lusine mais ce matin il faut
reprendre le rythme psa l'attend à 7h 30
précises personnellement je suis un
petit peu content parce que on passe
quand même énormément de temps madeco
lève on connaît beaucoup de gens ça fait
deux mois qu'on voit personne passe un
petit coup de téléphone de temps en
temps mais ça va faire plaisir un petit
peu de revoir les collègues des amis les
premières grandes sorties loin du
domicile direction l'entité fait rage de
peugeot sochaux david y est conducteur
d'installation depuis 18 ans sur le site
ce matin c'est d'abord masque
obligatoire dès le parking des affiches
le précise un peu partout on va être
plus prudentes l'habitude on va faire
plus attention et on verra on va vivre
avec
de toute manière pendant quelques temps
donc il va falloir qu'on s'habitue à
certains gestes qu'on n'avait pas
forcément avant mais on va le faire on
va suivre le mouvement
par mesure de sécurité le portail que
david empruntent habituellement est
condamné il faut que je passe par la
tante j'en suis pas sûr mais je me
demande si c'est pas par la bac ont une
partie de protocole
pour une grande partie du personnel le
passage se fera par sept grandes tentes
où l'on filtre les entrées avec prise de
la température corporelle et
distribution d'un petit paquetage
spécifique le gel bien évidemment pour
pouvoir se laver les mains et surtout le
plus important les deux masques que on
devra porter sur le site
ça va être une nouvelle façon de
travailler aussi certainement sur sur
les lignes de fabrication
ça sera des contraintes pour la
direction ça sera également des
contraintes là pour les salariés qui
travaillent tous les jours puisque
porter un masque
quand on est en ligne de montage c'est
pas forcément très simple depuis le 17
mars
aucune voiture n'a été produite à
sochaux aujourd'hui seulement 200
salariés ont repris le travail
sur la ligne de production des 308
uniquement pour le reste il faudra
attendre fin mai début juin